[Applause]
as time passes the rage does not
[Applause]
in liverpool more protests from ex-piano
staff and their supporters the message
unambiguous
save
it's 11 days since nearly 800 lost their
jobs with no notice or warning
many agency replacements are still
training up here drills and inspections
on ships stuck in port and there's a
sense things are strained we've been in
touch with someone aboard one of these
ships we've revoiced his words to
protect him
it's all panic preparation's a stop
start it's far from smooth
i feel very sad i feel bad for everyone
that's been sacked they've treated
everyone like animals
the atmosphere is far from normal i feel
like i'm in a strange city
the government wants him to know it's
doing more than just listening it wants
pno to know too
in a letter the transport secretary said
he'd use the law to block piano's plans
one last chance he said to change course
his team made clear they'll be left
little choice
piano ferries cannot
and will not be allowed to get away with
their actions
i hope the whole house will now support
our efforts to do just this
measures are likely to include minimum
wage obligations replacement crew now
are on an average of just five pound
fifty an hour there are other changes
piano have made like longer shift
patterns that would be harder for the
government to change but it clearly
wanted to lay down a marker that
undercutting workers in this way just
isn't acceptable pno will clearly be
saving less money than it bargained for
and the prospect of costly legal action
still hangs heavy
and that may still be an option for
unions they want all staff hired back a
case made at meetings today
we're looking at constructing a package
of measures this week
that will assist in the
process of bringing piano to account and
also restructuring the the british
shipping sector
piano says it welcomes the minimum wage
move many here might well ask why
they're not already paying it this row
has changed lives it could yet change a
whole industry helen and smith sky news